you've clicked on my face again that
means one of two things you just want to
hear me talk you want to hear me gush
about Star Trek ish things both are fine
and as the title of this video implies
the title I don't even know what I'm
gonna call it it's not a review really
I'll figure it out later but yes I
finally watched the Orville and for some
of you who don't know Star Trek the Next
Generation it's one of my favorite shows
of all time I think it's one of the
greatest shows ever made it's one of
those shows I like to have on running in
my house even if I'm not focused in and
watching it because I like the ambient
noise it brings by noise I mean
art next generation is timeless it's
profound it's thought provoking it's
fantastic so I heard about the show the
Orville I guess it started five years
ago now time does fly but I just heard
about it it was like oh Seth MacFarlane
it's kind of a love letter to Star Trek
I was like all right Family Guy in space
but love letters Star Trek so the story
is I have a friend who texts me one day
it was about a month ago and he was like
have you seen the Orville I I know you
love Star Trek I think you would like
this I was like oh Family Guy in space
he was like I totally like that and it
does you feel the Star Trek love there I
think he would like it I was like okay
finish the show and then let me know
what you think and by the end and maybe
I'll watch it then shortly after that I
found out that Brennan Braga is involved
with the Orville that's when production
knowing the production side of it very
helpful Brennan Braga producer and
writer on Star Trek the Next Generation
also worked on Voyager and Enterprise
and that's when it changed you know
hearing my friend go hey I know you you
would like this show that got my
curiosity but Brennan Braga got my
attention that's one of my perception of
the Orville changed entirely it went
from Seth MacFarlane does a love letter
to Star Trek to this creative team wants
to bring Star Trek back and keep it
alive because new Trek doesn't really
feel like Star Trek that's when I was
like all right all things considered
clocking in let's go and season one like
if you have that old guy maybe your dad
maybe it's your grandfather and they
love Star Trek and you have you want a
new show to show them Star Trek season
One's Gonna Be Tough because it does
have a lot of that I would call it Seth
MacFarlane humor back at Union Point we
called that a glory hole you called it a
glory hole nobody else called it a glory
hole no entering glory hole no Portis
it's not it's sir it's fine right
there's a lot of that situational
circumstance that humor that is driving
the show in season one I would call
season one a comedy some have called it
a parody it does ride that line however
even in that you do see the Trek love
there are some episodes where you're
like this definitely does feel like Star
Trek there's actually an episode in here
where it's like that is straight up
Black Mirror and it's about social media
there are actually situations where I'm
like I've seen that in Star Trek before
actually you're doing something that
Star Trek has done but you know it's
been decades since Star Trek so our
understanding of the universe that's
been expanded maybe maybe they can play
a little bit with that our social
constructs are a little different so
it's kind of fun to see something
Revisited that I recognize the theme of
bit from Star Trek the Next Generation
but it doesn't play out exactly the same
season two I feel like was when they
were like okay we are the Star Trek love
letter and that's our strength you know
it's not the humor it's not this being a
comedy the Star Trek love is the
strength of the show The Humor got
pushed back a bit the Star Trek got
pushed to the front and that's when it
shined a bit more not that the humor's
not in it it definitely still had that
humor I thought season two was a great
balance of humor in Star Trek to be
honest with you to the point where it it
kind of scratched that Firefly itch for
me you know where it's like it's a
comedy when it needs to be it gets
serious when it needs to be also season
two is when the show gets epic like it
actually grows in scale to the point
where they run into this situation
you're like oh that's gonna be a thing
kind of like the Dominion war in Deep
Space Nine where you're like okay we
have the show and we're also dealing
with that only instead of being stuck on
a space station the entire time you do
still have that space exploration going
on while the Situation's going down
season three is is called New Horizons
for no reason other than the fact that
it's now on Hulu but man you do see it
you see the fact they got some of that
[ __ ] you Hulu money kind of reminded me
again to reference Firefly it reminded
me if you're watching Firefly then you
watch Serenity and you're like oh yeah
it's that universe but with a bigger
budget you just see it in the production
of the show but that's when they were
like okay we're pulling back the comedy
a lot more filtering it through a couple
of characters namely Gordon and bordes
Gordon's he's the pilot kind of does
remind me of wash another Firefly
reference you know the funny pilot that
that's totally him bordes is kind of
like Drax you know he's very emotionless
but the things he says is they're it's
funny that's what makes it funny I will
be sure to bring my what does Lieutenant
Beloit call it my A-game there you go
buddy but I do feel bad for the cast in
season three at a point because season
three was when it was like okay we're
gonna stop making so many jokes gonna
filter most of the comedy through a
couple of characters which means Seth
MacFarlane you're now the captain so a
lot of times she's standing there all
Stern kind of [ __ ] his head and raises
an eyebrow while he's listening you feel
it most with Seth MacFarlane but you can
tell the entire crew I mean this got to
be tough right you sign on for this
comedy and now they're like no less
comedy more Star Trek probably tough to
roll with but I felt season three still
had those gem episodes that really shine
through one with Gordon I thought was
incredible guys in the end I just wanted
to give this show love I feel like it
deserves love it's moving to Disney Plus
in a few days it's on Hulu right now
both owned by Disney so they're getting
their money either way oh I've gone on
about it being a great Star Trek love
letter in its own right it's a great
show that stands on its own two legs the
adventures are great and thought
provoking in their own right added
bonuses it reminds me of something Star
Trek used to do I'm invested in the crew
I like their characters I have my
favorites of course I'm invested in
their relationships among each other you
know it's a show that has gripped me as
its own show also love to the late great
Norm McDonald's he plays a character or
he voices a character character in here
and there's some Star Trek alums that
make some appearances some actors that
you may recognize from other Star Trek
shows some of the old Star Trek shows
Next Generation Voyager Enterprise they
make some guest appearances in here I
mean they're probably actors taking on
roles for the reason most actors take on
roles for the paycheck but there's a
part of me that would just love to think
that it's because the actors are like oh
I see what this Show's doing right on
stamp of approval I get it there are a
lot of shows out there only so many
hours in a day or a week I get how it is
but if you are a Star Trek fan out there
and new Star Trek just isn't doing it
for you and you feel like something's
lost like you did what I did and you
kind of resigned yourself to the fact of
all right Star Trek as it was is just a
thing of the past we're not going to see
it anymore if you're looking for my
recommendation the Orville has it and
when I say the Orville is the best Star
Trek out right now I don't mean the
Orville compared to All Star Trek that
has ever been in the history of Star
Trek no what I mean is among new Star
Trek shows that have come out recently
and are coming out still to show that I
feel captures the spirit of Star Trek
the most is the show that's not
technically Star Trek and that is what I
wanted to talk with you about all right
so the Orville have you seen it what did
you think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
say more
[Music]